imaginemos un escenario en donde tú
necesitas desesperadamente un peso así
que vienes conmigo tu banquero de
confianza y me dices oye por favor
previsto un peso yo tengo vale te presto
un peso le prestes un peso y me lo
tienes que pagar en un año y como soy
muy buena onda te lo voy a cobrar a un
interés vamos a poner aquí un año y te
lo voy a cobrar con un interés de el
100% es decir después de un año tú me
vas a tener que pagar el peso el
principal que yo te preste un peso más
un peso de interés porque esto estoy
cobrando el 100% interés en un año
entonces me pagas un peso más un peso
que por supuesto ustedes que son muy
buenos con matemáticas dicen son dos
pesos bien
yo te digo bueno pero un año es mucho
tiempo que tal que tengo el dinero antes
entonces yo tengo pues no hay ningún
problema te puedo prestar el mismo peso
te voy a prestar un peso de nuevo y te
lo voy a prestar por seis meses seis
meses más o menos aquí está la mitad
seis meses
y durante esos seis meses lo que voy a
hacer es te voy a cobrar la mitad del
interés te voy a cobrar el 50% interés a
lo largo de esos seis meses y entonces
cuánto me tendrías que pagar me tendrías
que pagar el principal que es un peso
más el interés por este tiempo 50 por
ciento a lo largo de los seis meses 50
por ciento de 1 es 50 centavos así que
me tendrías que pagar uno más cincuenta
centavos que es uno con cincuenta
centavos
mejor la escribo por acá
un peso con 50 centavos 1 con 50
centavos bien pero qué pasa si no tengo
el dinero en ese momento qué pasa si
pasan los 6 meses y no te puedo pagar
pues no te preocupes hay un sistema para
eso lo que vamos a hacer es vamos a
hacer de cuenta que te presto ahora el
dinero que me tienes que pagar 1 con 50
y te lo presto por otros 6 meses otros 6
meses y de nuevo te lo presto con un
interés del 50 por ciento cuánto me
tienes que pagar ahora pues me tienes
que pagar un peso con 50 centavos que
sería el nuevo principal aunque eso con
50 centavos más los intereses a lo largo
de este periodo
es decir 50% de un peso con 50 centavos
es 75 centavos
y esto cuánto me da pues esto me da que
en total me tendrías que pagar 2 pesos
con 25 centavos lo cual ya no te gustó
tanto porque estás viendo que antes sólo
me tenías que pagar 2 piensas y ahora me
tienes que pagar 2 con 25 pero bueno
vamos a pensar en esto de otro modo que
me tengas que pagar 50% interés equivale
a tener que multiplicar por 1.5
por 1.5 el 1 viene de el capital inicial
y el punto 5 representa este 50% de
intereses así que 1 por 1.5 me da este
1.5 y de nuevo por acá tengo que
multiplicar por 1.5 para el segundo
periodo
así que 2.25 en realidad es lo mismo
esto es lo mismo que tomar el principal
inicial este peso y multiplicarlo por
mejor es otro color multiplicarlo por
1.5 dos veces en este caso en este caso
multiplicar algo por o tomar el 100%
interés equivale a multiplicar por 2
porque voy a tener que pagar el 100% así
que es dos veces la cantidad inicial de
modo que este 2 también lo podría
escribir común
mi principal inicial que es 1 x
a la potencia 1 2 a la 1 y eso me da
este 2 incluso otro modo de pensar en
esto y de este modo lo que no se
relaciona con el interés es simplemente
decir bueno pues esto es 1 x
uno que es simplemente me tienes que
pagar el uno que te prestes
más la parte que tiene que ver con el
interés que es el 100 interés
dividido entre el periodo en este caso
es un año solo hay un periodo elevado a
la potencia
bien
es más vamos a hacerlo así vamos a poner
el periodo entre 1 elevado a la potencia
1 y en este caso como sería pues sería
1 el principal inicial por 1 siempre voy
a tener este 1 + 100% 100%
recuerden 100% simplemente es 1 dividido
entre los periodos en este caso tengo
dos periodos así que entre 2 elevado
elevado
a la potencia 2
miren qué interesante y podemos
continuar este juego qué pasaría
qué pasaría si ahora te presto un peso
pero te lo presto en doce periodos de lo
presto por doce meses pues entonces
sería el primer mes
un mes
en el primer mes y te voy a cobrar qué
porcentaje intereses pues te voy a
cobrar 100 por ciento
100% entre 12 100 entre 12 es a 8 con un
tercio 8 con un tercio por ciento de
interés así que esto equivale a
multiplicar por 1.083 periódico así que
después de un mes me vas a tener que
pagar vas a tener que pagar un peso con
0 punto
83 con 8 un peso con 8 centavos y unas
cifras adicionales ok eso es el primer
mes y luego el segundo mes pasa otro mes
y ahora tengo que volver a multiplicar
por 1.0 83 y lo que voy a obtener es
1.0 83 periódico
al cuadrado porque es el segundo mes y
así continuamos así continuamos por
otros 10 meses
por otros 10 meses
déjenme lo escribo así y al final del
día me van a tener me vas a tener que
pagar
vas a tener que pagar un monto punto 083
periódico elevado a que potencia el
primer mes era la 1 y el segundo mes fue
la 2 así que el doceavo mes va a ser a
las 12
o escrito de otro modo esto es lo mismo
que mi principal inicial de 1
por uno más el 100 por ciento
el 100 por ciento dividido entre 12
periodos
al elevado todo eso
no tengo que componer consigo mismo por
12 periodos así que por 12 meses
elevado a la potencia 12 y cuánto es
esto
cuánto es esto pues sacamos nuestra
calculadora
y bueno esto es
no voy a anotar el 1 es uno más el 100%
que simplemente 1 dividido entre 12
elevado a la potencia 12
es 2.63 2.63 algo voy a redondear
simplemente ok esto se ve interesante
este número parece que no está creciendo
a lo loco sino que se acerca algo vamos
a ver ustedes como son intrépidos
matemáticos se preguntan qué pasa si
sigo jugando de este modo y ahora te
pido que me prestes un peso en un
periodo de un día así que vamos a hacer
esto por 365 365 periodos así que vamos
a hacerlo en intervalos de un día y el
interés va a ser del 100% dividido entre
365 así que cuánto va a ser esto no
tengo ni idea va a ser un numero
estratosférico yo creo veamos al final
esto va a ser igual
veamos nuestra fórmula 1 x
uno más el 100%
dividido entre 365 periodos perdón
estamos usando colores 365
periodos elevado a la potencia de 365 y
y que el número será eso parece que va a
ser un número gigantesco y casi
podríamos apostar te va a crecer mucho
pero recuerden 100 entre 365 va a ser un
número relativamente pequeño así que uno
más eso va a estar bastante cerca de 1 y
1 elevado a cualquier potencia es 1 así
que quizás no sea algo tan descabellado
a ver qué dice la calculadora
vamos a ver uno más uno entre 365
llevado a la potencia 365 es dos puntos
71 45 67 todos los puntos 71 45 algo dos
puntos 71 45 así que este número no está
creciendo tan rápido como uno esperaría
parece que nos estamos acercando un
valor definido a un número místico
mágico
no me gusta decir místico pero un número
especial y en verdad es lo que está
pasando cada vez nos estamos acercando
al quizás más impresionante de todos los
números en matemáticas y ese número se
llama y es más aquí su calculadora tiene
el botón de y vamos a poner lo que yo
voy a elevar al 1
2 puntos 71 82 ven como cada vez nos
estamos acercando más a este número que
es tan especial en matemáticas ese
número es el límite al que nos estamos
aproximando y los invito a poner cada
vez números más grandes aquí poner uno
más uno entre un número gigantesco y
elevarlo a la potencia de ese número y
van a ver como eso comienza a acercarse
a este número